قصفت قوات النظام السوري والمليشيات
الايرانيه مناطق شرقي حلب المحاصره كما
افاد ناشطون بان طائرات روسيه شاركت ايضا
في القصف الذي ياتي بعد انهيار اتفاق روسي
تركي لوقف اطلاق النار في حلب تبادلت
اطراف القتال المسؤوليه عن
البياض
اهلا بكم كان هذا خبر حلقتنا ونناقش فيما
وراءه ما مدى دقه الاتهامات المتبادله بين
اطراف القتال في حلب بشان المسؤوليه عن
انهيار اتفاق وقف اطلاق النار في المدينه
ثم ما هي فرص نجاح محاولات انقاذ الاتفاق
وما هي الخيارات التي تملكها الاطراف
المعنيه بالازمه السوريه في حال
فشله
على وقع حديث عن استمرار محاولات انقاذ
الاتفاق التركي الروسي لمعالجه الاوضاع في
حلب الشرقيه تؤكد الانباء الوارده من هناك
استمرار قوات النظام السوري وحلفائها من
الميليشيات الطائفيه في قصف الاحياء
المتبقيه تحت سيطره المعارضه السوريه
المسلحه في شرق حلب قصف يفيد ناشطون بان
الطائرات الروسيه ايضا تشارك فيه بينما لا
تزال المسؤوليه عن انهيار الاتفاق محل
خلاف بين اطراف القتال ورعاه الاتفاق
نتابع تقرير ناصر ايت الطاهر ثم نفتح
النقاش مع
ضيوفنا حلب هل من مخرج ليس مجرد سؤال ففي
الاجابه عليه اما حياه او موت لساعات
معدوده كان امل قد لاح للمحاصرين اليائسين
من ابناء حلب الشرقيه
هدنه وخروج امن لمقاتلي المعارضه
والمدنيين باتجاه ريف حلب الغربي لا شيء
من ذلك تم فكانما جاء الاتفاق لرفع العتب
عن مجتمع دولي ليس غضب بعضه بحجم ما
تقاسيه حلب اذا سمعت نظام الاسد يقول انه
لا علم له بالاتفاق فاعلم انه قد يكون
صادقا هذه المره فما عاد يملك قراره
الاتفاق اعلنه الروس وقيل ان ميليشيات
ايرانيه عجلت
بانهياره لكن الاسد وحلفائه راوا في
الهجوم خير دفاع فقد اتفقوا على وضع فصائل
من المعارضه المسلحه في دائره الاتهام
تاره باطلاق النار على الحافلات المخصصه
لاجلاء المدنيين وتاره باغتنام الهدنه
لمحاوله خرق مواقع قوات النظام والحقيقه
ان تلك القوات والميليشيات المتحالفه معها
كما تؤكد المعارضه هي من قصفت بالمدفعيه
مناطق شرقيه حلب المحاصره ضمن محاولات
افشال الاتفاق وتلك محاولات قادتها ايران
كما يبدو يقول معارض سوري ان الاتفاق كان
بين المقاتلين وروسيا بواسطه تركيه ولا
يتضمن ايران لكنها هي من احبطت اذ منعت
خروج الحافلات التي تقل الجرحى واوعز
لقوات النظام باستئناف قصف الاحياء
المحاصره في اجزاء حلب الشرقيه كما اشترط
الجانب الايراني للسماح بسريان اتفاق حلب
خروج الجرحى من قريتي الفوع وكفريا
الشيعيين المحاصرتين شمال ادلب وكذا اطلاق
المعارضه المسلحه عشرات الاسر لديها من
حركه النجباء
العراقيه اما موسكو التي دابت على سوق
اعذار شتى للتنصل من اي تسويه او هده او
اتفاق فيكفي ان طيرانها الحربي يواصل قصف
شرقي حلب بينما يبشر باستم رار عمليات
قوات النظام السوري العسكريه هناك فهل كان
الروس يناور بالاتفاق الذي اثمرت جهود
وساطه تركيه املا في حل ينهي ماساه حلب
يتحدث البعض عن استراتيجيه روسيه لزياده
المكاسب السياسيه والميدانيه من اتفاق حلب
مع ذلك لم تتوقف الاتصالات بين انقره
وموسكو حتى على مستوى القياده اتصالات
يتفاءل بها الروس ويقولون انها مختلفه عما
عهدوه مع
الامريكيين فهل يتوقعون ان تطمئن تلك
الكلمات اولئك المحاصرين في رقعه جغرافيه
لا تزيد على ثلاثه كيلومترات
مربعه موضوع حلقتنا هذا نناقشه مع ضيوفنا
من غاز عنتاب زكريا ملاحفجي رئيس المكتب
السياسي لتجمع
فاستقم احد فصائل المعارضه السوريه مسلحه
ومن اسطنبول محمد زاهد جل الكاتب والباحث
السياسي التركي ومن موسكو الكساندر
براتسك الكاتب الصحفي المختص في الشؤون
الخارجيه بصحيفه جازيت نرحب بضيوفنا جميعا
وابدا معك في اسطنبول سيد زاهد جول يعني
هناك اتهامات من كل الاطراف بافشال هذا
الاتفاق برايك
تركيا تحمل من مسؤوليه افشال هذا
الاتفاق تركيا بشكل رسمي تحمل النظام
السوري
و حلفاء النظام السوري سواء من المليشيات
الشيعيه بشكل رئيسي سواء ايرانيه كانت او
لبنانيه او
عراقيه فشل هذا الاتفاق ولنتحدث عن الهدنه
وعن هذا الاتفاق بشكل سريع حتى يكون
المشاهد على علم واطلاع يعني الاتفاقيه
المطروحه اصلا هي اتفاقيه ليست جديده هي
اتفاقيه او الورقه التي قدمها ديمستورا
قبل اشهر وتم التوافق عليها امريكيا روسيا
لكن الفشل الروسي الامريكي في التوصل الى
اتفاق فيما يتعلق بحلب ادخلت تركيا على خط
هذه المحادثات و يعني منذ اكثر من شهر
نشاهد دبلوماسيه تركيا في اطار ما يمكن ت
تميته بوضع حد لهذه الاتفاقيه او او بمعنى
اخر او بمعنى ادق تطبيق وتنفيذ هذه الهدنه
المرجوه في حلب وفي الاسبوعين الماضيين
حقيقه كانت هناك لقاءات بشكل واضح برعايه
تركيا بين فصائل المعارضه وبين روسيا بشكل
مباشر في انقره تم التوصل فيها على اتفاق
مبدئي لكن هذا الاتفاق ايضا لم يتم تنفيذه
واستمر مرت العمليات العسكريه في حلب وفي
هذه اللحظات بعد ان اعلن حقيقه الهدنه
بالامس
لازالت كل الامور في حلب كما هي عليه
ق بمعنى انه لم يخذ نعم تقول الوضع مازال
كما هو عليه في حلب وان تركيا تحمل رسميا
النظام السوري والميليشيات الشيعيه
المدعومه من ايران المسؤوليه عن افشال
الهدنه هل ابلغت تركيا هذا الموقف
لروسيا نعم اعتقد انها ابلغت لروسيا وهناك
تواصل تائب اصلا مع المسؤولين الروس
واخرها ما هو مذكور حقيقه في الخبر العاجل
في الجزيره في الوقت الراهن ان هناك
اتصالا هاتفيا بين اردوغان وبين بوتين وفي
هذا اليوم كان هناك محادثات تركيه مع
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ومع وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي وكذلك كانت هناك
محادثات مع السكرتير العام او الامين
العام الجديد للامم المتحده وتواصل ايضا
اكثر من دوله في يتعلق
بضغوطات نعم اذا كان الامر هكذا ما
تفسيركم اذا لاشتراك الطيران الروسي في
القصف بعد
الاتفاق في قصف
حلب يعني يبدو ان يعني اعتقد شخصيا ان هذا
محاوله لشراء الوقت او محاوله شرع
القتل والمزيد من القتل في مربع صغير
ذكرتموه بانه 3 ك مت مربع يعني هذا في هذه
المنطقه الان يقطن قرابه 70 الف انسان
بحسب احصائيات الامم المتحده او بحسب
ارقام الامم المتحده ويوجد هناك خلال
الايام الماضيه و خلال الساعات الماضيه ما
يزيد على الالف قتيل والاف الجرحى الذين
يحتاجون الى من يمد اليهم يد العون
والمساعده طيب الكسندر براث ريسكي يعني
هناك اتهامات صريحه وواضحه
ل الاطراف التي ذكرها الان محمد زاهد جل
للنظام والسوري ولملي الشيات الشيعيه
المدعومه لايران ولكن ايضا روسيا شاركت في
استمرت في القصف بعد التوصل لهذا الاتفاق
وهذا ما عرقل او افشل هذا الاتفاق تتحمل
اذا موسكو المسؤوليه عن افشال الاتفاق
اليس كذلك
ي مساء الخير نعم نعم
هناك جريمه حرب الان في حلب واستهداف
المدنيين من قبل الطائرات ويجب القيام
بتحقيق في هذا السياق اذا كانت روسيا
مسؤوله فيجب محاسبه روسيا في هذا الصدد
هناك لنقل انهيار الثقه ما بين هذه
الاطراف ليس هناك ثقه بال النظام السوري
ولا المليشيات الشيعيه وروسيا ايضا ومن
الصعب الان الوصول الى ارضيه توفقيه لان
الولايات المتحده الان ايضا منشغله بنتائج
الانتخابات الامريكيه والاداره الامريكيه
الجديده التي ستتسلم دوال الحكم
فيى المو عن
الاه برا كي نفهم الموقف الروسي لماذا
تستانف روسيا قصف حلب وهي قد تفاهمت مع
توصلت الى اتفاق وقف اطلاق النار مع
تركيا لا يمكنني ان اجيب بالنيابه عن
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ولكن
اعتقد ان
هكذا اتفاقيات دائما انهارت في الماضي
والوزاره وزاره الدفاع الروسيه تقول
بان المعارضه هي التي كانت تخرق هذا
الاتفاق وهي تستغل الهدنه ل اعاده ترتيب
صفوفها انا لا احاول ان ابرر الامر انا لا
امثل وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ولكن ربما هذا
هو تفسير الجانب الروسي لاستئناف قصف حلب
ومشاركه الط
الروسيه وللاسف هذا هو الوضع عندما كانت
الحرب في الشيشان والحرب في اوكرانيا هذا
هو التفسير الذي عاده يقدم في هكذا حالات
وهكذا
وضعيات اذا لا اعتقد ان روسيا ستحقق
الكثير من خلال هذه الهجمات هذا على العكس
شيء
سيس نعم ماذا
تحقق
لا اعتقد ان روسيا بامكانها ان تصل الى اي
شيء من خلال
هذا القصف المتجدد على حلب
والمدنيين و الشيء
الوحيد هو ان هناك تنسيق صعب الان ما بين
النظام نعلم ان بشار الاسد يستخدم روسيا
التخفي وراء ما يحدث وهناك اخبار تفيد بان
الاسد يحاول ان يطيل امد الازمه ويحاول ان
يطيل امد الحرب واعتقد ان الوضع
الان ان كل الاطراف تحاول ان تمضي في هذا
زكريا ملاحفجي يعني انتم في المعارضه ما
تفسيركم لاقدام النظام وحلفائه ب خرق
الاتفاق المتوصل اليه لوقف اطلاق
النار نعم اختي الكريمه بدايه اول شغله
نسال سؤال هل الروس صدقوا ولو مره واحده
على الاطلاق في كل المبادرات والهد التي
كانت تطرح الروس لم يصدقوا ولا مره واحده
كانوا يراوغ على الاطلاق يعني من مفاوضات
انقره في اليوم الثاني تنسف بالكامل بعد
ما يتم الاتفاق على بنود الى اتفاق اي ما
بين موسكو واشنطن على سته بنود ثم تنسف ثم
اتفاق بوقع عليه ضابط روسي سفش كو الموجود
في في في حلب وبيوقع عليه مسؤول عمليات
العسكريه والامنيه في حلب من قبل النظام
ثم ينسف بوقع عليه ثم ينسف في اليوم
الثاني بشكل واضح يعني ال صار الحديث عن
خروج جرحى ثم المقاتلين ومن يرغب من
المدنيين اي الجرحى تجهزوا للخروج واذ انه
تتعطل بعده اعذار وحجج اي بيطلع الصباح
وتبدا العمليات العسكريه بشكل عنيف جدا
هناك مراوغه لشراء وقت سعي للسيطره
للاباده للقتل ماساه انسانيه ترتكب بحلب
للاسف للمجتمع الدولي ول الام المتحده
استطاع ان يعني يحقق ممر امن لهؤلاء
الجرحى للمصابين وهم بالالاف اللي عم يبحث
عن دواء وعن خبز وعن علاج وعم يبحث عن
حياه كل الم درات التي طرحت واللي
المعارضه التزمت وجاءت يعني الان الصوره
الاخيره بحلب بشكل واضح موسكو قفزت من
انقره الى واشنطن وجنيف الى حتى المفاوضات
المباشره مع مع الفصائل ومع ذلك نسفت كل
ذلك الايرانيين يحققون النفوذ ومشروعهم
اللي عم يسعوا له
والروس بهذا الشكل للاسف ما يحصل شيء يعني
عجيب معركه قذره تخاف ومراوغه كاذبه غير
واضحه وماسات انسانيه تكبر ليس كل يوم ولا
كل ساعه بل كل دقيقه وكل لحظه اليوم
صواريخ فراغيه قنابل عنقوديه بالراج مات
ما يحصل في حلب شيء كبير اكبر من الوصف
والصور والكلمات الانسانيه فعلا تذبح امام
صمت وامام يعني اعاقه المجتمع الدولي على
انه يفعل شيء حقيقه هذا الوضع وهذا الم ه
في
حلب وبقوا بهذا هذه المرا الوضع امام هذا
الوضع
وافشال
اتفاق وقف اطلاق النار المتوصل اليه بوسطه
تركيه سوف نناقش بعد الفاصل خيارات اطراف
اتفاق وقف اطلاق النار في حلب بعد انهيار
هذا الاتفاق ولكن بعد الفاصل فلا تذهبوا
بعيدا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مجددا مشاهدينا الى هذه الحلقه
التي تناقش اسباب انهيار اتفاق وقف اطلاق
النار في حلب واخي اطراف الاتفاق بعد
انهياره نعود الى ضيوفنا محمد زاهد جول في
اسطنبول يعني تركيا صحيح انها تقوم بدور
وساطه ولكنها لا تملك في الحقيقه اوراق
ضغط كبيره لا تملك اطلاقا وليس كبيره
اوراق ضغط لا على النظام السوري لا على
روسيا لا على ايران اوراق الضغط التي
بيدها هي فقط على المعارضه على الطرف
الضعيف هل تبدو برايك اذا تركيا مؤهل هلا
للعب دور وساطه ودور الضامن لاي
اتفاق اعتقد لا يعني على الاقل من و ما
طلبته روسيا حقيقه من المعارضه ا قد تم
تنفيذه وتم تلبيته وبالتالي لا لا اعتقد
ان هناك اوراق حقيقه سياسيه في الوقت
الراهن يمكن اللعب بها وخاصه ان الماساه
بلغت الى حاله مزر جدا يعني نحن نتحدث عن
هدنه يتم الحديث عنها منذ اشهر وهذه
الهدنه لم تتحقق وعديد من الاتفاقيات كلها
حقيقه لم تتحقق انا في قناعتي لم يبقى
هناك الا ما يمكن تسميته بالخيار العسكري
المحدود الذي ربما يفتح الطريق امام
المدنيين على الاقل من اجل الخروج
وبالتالي يعني اعتقد انه لم يعد هناك خيار
اخر يعني خيار الدبلوماسيه اذا لم تتحقق
في هذه لله حقيقه ولم تستطع ان تؤتي اكلها
فاننا امام ماساه انسانيه حقيقيه لا يوجد
معها اعتقد من الحلول الا ما يمكن تسميته
باستخدام القوه العسكريه المحدوده على
الاقل لفتح ممرات امنه انسانيه ولا واتصور
ان تركيا لو قامت بمثل هذا العمل وهذه
قناعتي الشخصيه لن تكون هناك حرب عالميه
ثالثه ولن تكون هناك
ارتدادات لهذه ال القوه العسكريه التي
ستستخدمها تركيا اذا كانت محدوده واذا
كانت من اجل فتح ممرات انسانيه وهذا ما
اتمناه شخصيا كمراقب لهذا المشهد الماساوي
الاليم نعم الكسندر برات ريسكي برايك ما
الذي يمكن ان تطالب
به موسكو في المفاوضات الجاريه الان بخصوص
الاتفاق اتفاق وقف اطلاق
النار حسنا روسيا مهتمه
ب انقاد ما الوجه في الوقت الراهن وحسب ما
اعلم روسيا تود ان تخرج من هذا الم المازق
باسرع وقت ممكن لان الامور ايضا تتعقد
بالنسبه لروسيا نظرا للضحايا المدنيين
وللضغط من قبل الغرب اذا روسيا تبحث عن
مخرج ولكن النظام يحب او يريد ان تب ق
روسيا لفتره اطول وهناك حديث ايضا عن من
قبل الغرب عن بدلاء للاسد وربما روسيا
ستبقى الى حين الايجاد بديل للاسد اذا
اعتقد ان روسيا
الان تحاول
ان تجد مخرجا لهذه الازمه وانا افهم ان
روسيا الان تحاول ان تحسم الامر مع الم
طيب ما الذي يمكن نعم انتقل الى زكريه
ملاحفجي ما الذي يمكن ان تقدمه المعارضه
لانقاذ هذا
الاتفاق سيدتي بالنسبه
للاتفاق المعارضه والفصائل في كل ما طرح
في المرات الماضيه من هدن واتفاقات في
واشنطن وجنيف وانقره واتفاقات مبا شره
التزمت باي مسار ممكن يحقق تهدئه ويحقق
حتى حل سياسي لكن التوحش والتغول بدماء
السوريين و ونسف كل المفاوضات وكل التهدئه
[موسيقى]
واللجلجة نسفه من قبل الروس والنظام
والايرانيين بقي المسار العسكري المسار
العسكري هو الصمود ستتحول الفصائل داخل
حلب الى مشاريع شهاده حقيقه وحتى الفصائل
خارج حلب هناك مظاهرات الان تخرج لحث كل
الفصائل رح تفتح معارك كبيره صحيح ان
المعركه غير متكافئه بالنسبه ل الترسانه
العسكريه الروسيه امام الفصائل لكن ستكون
هناك مواجهه عس عسكريه حقيقيه اليوم الشعب
السوري اللي عم يهجر ويطرد من بيوته ومن
مدينته الى
اخره نعم اشكرك واعتذر منك لانتهاء وقت
البرنامج شكرا لك زكريا ملاحفجي رئيس
المكتب السياسي لتجمع فاستقم كنت معنا من
غزي عنتاب ونشكر ايضا من اسطنبول محمد
زاهد ج الكاتب والباحث السياسي التركي ومن
موسكو الكساندر براث ريسكي بهذا تنتهي هذه
الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء الخبر لكم من
اطيب المنى والى
[موسيقى]
اللقاء